ciao a tutti ciao a tutti ciao a tutti
ace i ragazzi lo ammetto lo ammetto mi
batto il petto mi è dispiaciuto non
poter fare video in quest'ultimo periodo
però sono stato molto impegnato comunque
stiamo riflettendo lo ferma ferma qui a
noi inizi sempre con stabili flettendo
cambia
[Musica]
mi è venuto in mente così va la colonna
ho recentemente preso in considerazione
è troppo accademica che cosa qualcosa
che gli scialli stavo ha pensato troppo
mourinho ecco è questo già meglio
continua così nel mi raccomando ok
quindi stavo pensando recentemente a una
cosa esistono due tipi diversi di
critiche la prima è il tipo di critica
carina costruttiva hubble the demolente
però in ogni caso basata su qualcosa di
nuovo si sta facendo notte no la seconda
è quella invece fatta per sport quella
messa proprio antipatico perché forse
perché se la tira troppo troppo ego 103
comiche dice stai scherzando ma resta
sempre un ulteriore sarà che mi sarà
anche mina l'impressione di essere un
immaturo cioè proprio uno di quelli che
non sa prendersi una responsabilità è
sposato con carmen ha un figlio e lavora
tutti i giorni pure la domenica
non lo so non lo so se sarà il mito che
è un po così tipo quindi non lo so non
lo reggo no ti spiego come piace
moltissimo fare video perché ti piace
non ho adesso voglio sapere perché
divertente in un penso di farlo per
cercare fama ma anche no cioè non mi
sarei messo le parrucche sembra ridicolo
più che altro centrico keiko centrico
pensa di far vivere non dicevo allora
appesa nelle parole perché hanno un
significato ma tu prima hai detto tu
stai sempre a pesare le parole sembra
possano fare questa sono solo me stesso
è arrivato il santo signori carteggi
questo povero figlio ma che non sono
tanto per niente bene disse il vuoto
vuoto solo io ti vedo per quello che sai
un pallone gonfiato pieno di nulla
tra comprato complimenti no no no tu sei
il male se il demonio 6 satana
[Musica]
certo che selvaggi è molto carina
secondo me no ecco se dobbiamo dirla
tutta un pochino tondeggiante un po
pingue paffutella pinguin argine un po
fochi calo è per non parlare degli occhi
verdi hebron avvenuto così della bocca
un po banale banale scontata katelynas e
tayone scarl ai tester team angeli
napoli nicole kidman alessia pelonzi
tutte quante uguali questa attricette da
strapazzo
morale della favola se state sulle palle
una persona tranquilli perché perché
continuerà criticarvi qualsiasi cosa voi
facciate anche quando aiuterete i
terremotati di haiti lei continuerà a
criticare anche quando troverete da soli
la cura per il cancro continuerà a
criticarli e molto probabilmente
continuerà a criticarli anche quando
cercherete di salvarle la vita facendo
quelle cose tipo avresti potuto salvarne
la metà di loro vita e voi direte guarda
chi non sto a criticare sempre critico
solo quando penso che ci sia veramente
qualcosa di sbagliato allora sorridi
perché non sto parlando con te quindi
levati dalle palle non sono ragazzi non
vi è mai successo di essere criticati di
una persona che poi non ha criticato ciò
che ha criticato a voi e con un suo
amico
fatelo sapere un commento qui sotto in
un video risposta bello quanto del liceo
un commento